[Musique]
alors bonjour à la planète en direct de
montréal il est 11 heures 19 minutes et
tomtom canada oui je sais nous avons
huit minutes de retard sur notre envol
et habituel c'est normal vous allez voir
pourquoi c'est normal que ça se produise
aujourd'hui cette histoire là nous ça
change pas quand et où de retard ou pas
on enfile on arrivera bien alors qu'on
doit arriver n'est pas de limite de
temps dans ses émissions sur le web
comme dit l'animateur avant son renvoi
alors autour data bien raymond des
marteaux bonjour marie jobin bonjour
marie claude sénécal sénégal le on va
devenir un saint le sujet de l'émission
mal qu'on ne peut pas jouer parce que
vous connaissez je suis je vous avez
joué dans les vidéos tout préparé vous
avez aucune idée aucune idée je fais ça
je me disant de vraiment où est capable
vous avez deux des femmes ils ont deux
cerveaux et ou courtier reste beaucoup
médité
vidéo cinq images vous grillez dès que
vous sentez que vous savez le compare
aujourd'hui on regarde ça ensemble
voilà ses participants de tintin bon
départ we re la technologie ça pourrait
que ça aviation vols retardés ou vegas
sur la bonne piste mais on parle d'
annulation
ça confirme d'intérêt il a l'air triste
plus ouais ouais mais les problèmes une
fois que les vols sont retardés donc
essentielle ment je dirais que ce serait
quoi
le ministre des transports qui est une
année au canada
il a fait son annonce le ministre qu'on
a vu il ya un instinct marc garneau ex
astronaute canadien dans les années 80
il a fait son annonce ou plombier la rb
oui c'est le premier qui a fait son
annonce
c'était le 17 attendez voir 17 décembre
le ch poste lundi - 18 je prenais
l'avion même endroit à l' aéroport
international d'ottawa oui je t'ai donc
j'ai retardé mon départ parce que je
voulais que tu m'as voir ce qu'il avait
à dire par rapport aux nouveaux droits
des passagers
ça rentrera en vigueur ce ctt portes cet
été d'accord et je vais vous donner une
idée de des récompenses qu on va vous
offrir comme passager au canada ça
ressemble beaucoup à ce qui se passe on
copie un peu l'initiative européen dans
ce domaine on va pas récompensés mais on
voit ils ont réparé on va faire le
pauvre clients qui voit son vol retardé
ou annulé par ce vent une compensation
financière beaucoup plus élevé que ce
qui était prévu à l'origine en ce moment
voici premier tour de la grosse boule
vraiment dingue
il ya du bouton pas ce fait c'est bien
fait alors voici combien de boules à
perdre une d'accord alors il ya symbole
à perdre par émission il ya tout un jeu
danois cas d'accord c'est pas ça fait
longtemps c'est pas venu en fait très
longtemps
voici la nouvelle charge été affectés
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce gouvernement
demande la lune charte canadienne des
droits des passagers va donc entrer en
en retard mais entrée en vigueur très
bientôt cet été les paiements passagers
dont les vols seront retardés ou annulés
vont atténuer ou vont atteindre au
maximum quel montant est-ce que c'est à
1000 $ b 2000 $ ou est ce que c'est
c'est 3000 $ pour les retards qui serait
assez long est ce qu'une quatrième à
monsieur b aucune de ces réponses
diab et denise b 2000 dollars maximum
comme récompense d'accord b 2 mai 2000
bingo en suède et aucune de ces réponses
des c'est pas ça va être aussi généreux
regardez ce qui m'a fait ce n'est pas
prévu avant que vous choisissez vous
gérez de comprendre
ouais c'est quoi à b ou c mai 2000 ou
3000 $ je dirais ah ah ah c'est la bonne
réponse tous les autres vous ont peur du
point seulement 1000 dollars
mais vous pourriez perdre des points
mais je voulais vous les laisse
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai écouté voici
la réponse
les paiements aux passagers dont les
vols sont retardés ou annulés atteint au
maximum 1000 dollars mais jusqu'à 2400
dollars après un refus d'embarquement
causée par une raison
ration excédentaire de la part de votre
transporteur inquiète donc j'accepte
plus d'accord price a fait voilà vous
perdrez vos autres points plus tard les
gens les 50 à perdre plus tard les pas
de programme est vaste et on va aller
dans notre invité oui qui va grever plus
vous pouvez notre invité on a là deux
aujourd'hui
alors il s'agit de quelqu'un qui est
vraiment longue aux demandes des
voyageurs c'est un des nombreux au
canada il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
porte à la défense des pauvres voyageurs
beaucoup de voyageurs d'abord et puis je
sais pas si c'est un commerce si on fait
de l'argent avec ça voici monsieur jacob
charbonneau président directeur général
de vols en retard bonjour vous nous
entendez bien magnifique des sur dix se
comme on dit à la radio
et est ce que vous ne voyez bien comme
on dit à la télévision en couleurs à
part de ça écoutez je sais pas si on
peut aller sur votre site qui s'appelle
vols en retard
est ce que ces points ca au point comme
point ca
pendant le fait de notre conversation on
y arrivera sans doute sur votre site
parce que j'y ai trouvé là une façon
assez rapide de pouvoir me plains d'une
compagnie aérienne sans avoir à chercher
vers qui me diriger pour me plaindre
vous êtes un peu l'entonnoir pour le
passager est-ce que vous recevez une
ristourne
une partie de l'argent la compensation
qui est offerte aux voyageurs parce que
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
partagés en charge aussi ce vraiment un
service des jurés se pencher sur le dos
aussi aller chercher des femmes
maximales sont prévues au niveau de la
loi
et lorsque l'on gagne crozon garde un
pourcentage de 25 pour ça donc nous on
est payé par la vigne et aérienne
regarde 30 âgées qu'on verse de
maintenance aux clients je voudrais
qu'on présente la vidéo numéro 3 qu'on a
préparé pour cette émission ça s'appelle
indemnités pour voir en retard et on
s'est fié à une diagramme préparé par
radio canada qui lors de l'annoncé par
le ministre marc garneau a lancé donc
les montants en gros qu'on pourrait
recevoir
c'est au niveau d'une zone sais pas si
comme ça que ça va vraiment se passer
mais voici ce qu'on prévoit en principe
offrir aux clients 3 6 heures de retard
400 dollars c'est beaucoup
selon le taux horaire de raymond c'est
quand même pas très fort 6 à 9h07
cendrars 9 heures ou plus 1000 $ ça
c'est payant c'est un conte fait ça
semble alléchant enfin en cela on a
l'impression la queue on va respire un
peu plus ça va coûter cher à une
compagnie de prendre une mauvaise
décision elle va y réfléchir deux fois
qu'est ce que vous en pensez en fait une
extension quand on regarde les montants
qui auraient pu refaire effectivement ça
va par contre on regarde en profondeur
le règlement qui était proposé qu'ils
méritent en vigueur le 1er juillet on se
rend compte que ce règlement qui est
très en surface mais qu'il n'y a pas de
profondeur derrière il ya très peu
d'imputabilité haut niveau les
transporteurs à la vienne ce qui laisse
la place à beaucoup de porte de sortie à
pour ne pas verser les mêmes versions
auprès des passagers
et d'ailleurs est ce que ce plan-là
petit décrié par des gens qui sont dans
d'autres pays comme étant un plat qui
est vraiment un peu en bottes de ce
conte d'offres ailleurs oui exactement
s'est elle écriée dans vos pays cette
habitude est aussi ici au canada
nous on ne participe donc on lui tient
la forme
c'est en jouant sous l'ère plusieurs
lacunes donc aux lacunes au niveau 1 du
règlement pas pour oser et des points
qui vont vraiment favoriser donc on me
fait des choix politiques au bout
le fils de 30 joueurs du canadien qui
avantage et non vous êtes parmi tous
ceux présents ici peut-être le plus
voyageurs le plus fréquent ça a été une
période
marie-claude vous allez vous vous faire
voyager le plus loin vous avez donc de
l'expérience de la mauvaise expérience
accumulée pas beaucoup de vous avez des
questions pour l'inviter oui et je me
demandais en fait comment est-ce qu'on
procède avec ce nouveau règlement là
quand je mange des aéroports il ya trois
heures de retard je suis insatisfait
qu'est ce que je fais à mon retour de
voyage pour obtenir les indemnités quand
je procède à n'importe qui avec
n'importe quelle famille un peu importe
l'origine ou la destination
donc quand les gens dont son attitude en
leur temps pour sa famille
ils peuvent le faire indirectement sur
leur cellulaire nous pas en reste
puisqu'on fait vraiment vos soirées
intelligent à 20h qui se tourne et où on
veut leur prix le service complet le
client mais pas le chercher les limites
et il s'assure et où surtout tant qu'on
est mais on n'est pas obligé de faire
affaire avec vous il ya d'autres options
c'est pour le peuple ce sera quoi les
autres options si je tapais courant que
vous existez ce que ce poteau monde est
au courant que vous existez en retard
[Musique]
pour cent des gens quitter l'egypte une
compensation qui allait enfin parce
qu'ils étaient simplement concours en
donc oui les 35 semble évidemment les
gens peuvent soit voir une assurance
comme une préparation alors assuré m
[Musique]
différents besoins des différentes
solutions il ya le fond mais bennie peek
et des agences de voyages qui exige donc
il ya différents recours peuvent être
pris tout dépendamment de la situation
des différents règlements concept qui va
quand par exemple européen doit
s'appliquer sur les vols canada du
nouveau cinéma canadien et surtout le
canadien il ya donc type de règlement au
bout de propositions qui sont prévues à
travers le thème quand les conditions
dans mes cheveux mouillés l'avion a donc
tout dépendamment de la situation
commence à montréal qui permet aussi
d'aller chercher les montants pour
autant l'action commencée internationale
et chercher
merci monsieur charbonneau où vous avez
utilisé un terme un peu plus tôt que je
mettrais un contexte également avec
l'augmentation une quasi exponentielle
du nombre de vols et des deux voyageurs
surtout avec le tourisme de masse qu'on
connaît maintenant c'est le terme de
l'imputabilité vous qui se définit
différemment un peu partout et ici est
ce que l'imputabilité a été je dirais
sous-traité par papa mode de lobbying de
la part des grands transporteurs auprès
du ministre auriez vous écoutez je
trouve à votre choix de monde que
intéressant et réfléchit à quand on
regarde si on se comprend tout ce qu'ils
fardeau leurs efforts même dans des
circonstances extraordinaires au niveau
européen
si le fardeau de la preuve revient après
la ligne aérienne
doit démontrer qu'elles ont fait tout en
leur pouvoir pour éviter la situation
mais une situation qui à leur contrôle
ou qu'ils se concentrent extraordinaire
notion akira qui est complètement
absente au niveau du règlement canapé
lorsqu'arrive une situation la ligne
aérienne votre démontrer niveau européen
toujours à que sinon on ira au service
afin avant transporterait donc par
exemple un avion qui percute un chariot
à bagages sur 20 sur une piste donc ça
devient une erreur au service qui est
offert un premier temps retenu 21
complètement à l'opposé aux nouveaux cas
mais lorsqu'on annuler un vol
transportant devoir démontrer qu'ils ont
encore une 905 m
nouveaux canadiens pour le titre c'est
qu'on a mis quatre capitales on a mis
des catégories donc la première sur des
situations qui sont attribuables aux
transporteurs la deuxième situation
attribuable aux transporteurs mais
nécessaire par souci sécurité notamment
les britanniques qui ne donne pas le roi
des cons française ensuite on exclut les
défaillances mécaniques qui ont ils
relevé au niveau de la maintenance qui
complètement impossible pour le passage
de sa mort dit on m'a pas mal faut
oublier tout ce qui est indépendant à la
volonté divine
on a quatre types de situations sont
assez floues et où il n'ya pas de faire
vos preuves au niveau 1 du transporteur
donc pu en discuter de ces points avec
l'office de transports canada puisqu'on
vous ce qui porte à gauche non plus sur
le partage du parc en charger aucune
façon ça moi ils m'ont lui oui moi
j'avais une question à propos du bris
mécanique
on sait qu'aux états unis en ce moment
ya des entreprises a rien qui ne font
peur un entretien adéquat et là vous
dites que en cas de bris mécanique
au canada le le passage ils ne seraient
pas indemnisés sont eux mêmes problèmes
canada qu'est ce qui arrive quand c'est
la faute peut-être du transporteur
qui n'a pas fait un entretien adéquat
évidemment il ya des normes très sévères
l'institut est un goût de transport m
donc évidemment la vie par contre on
parle d'indemnisation ou de prise en
charge des passagers complètement
excuses de chlef la rentabilité donc
c'est l'europe où ça va vous boude pas
pour ne pas verser des compensations
fille de m plein de situations qui
pourraient amener sociabilité par contre
le passage monsieur charbonneau merci
beaucoup de nous avoir apporté ces
informations là aussi maintenant quand
vous répondez à la question de
marie-claude on sentait vraiment que tu
es le plusieurs du ans dans les dents
tout ce qu'on pouvait obtenir deux
transporteurs est conseillé de faire
affaire avec un avocat
à défaut d'un avocat
on peut se tourner vers vous donc
président directeur général de vols en
retard merci beaucoup au revoir
alors je vais vous montrer quelque chose
vous avez tous été témoins de ça c'est
un fait le tour du monde c'était la
vidéo de la semaine un certain moment
donné on va se reporter à au 9 avril
1917 et les absences 1917 juillet 2010
7-1 bonnement d'europe de rugby une
vidéo 2009
alors on va regarder ça c'est on a
appelé ça cinq vidéos 5 expulsé de son
siège avec sar s'il vous plaît on veut
le son pour entendre
pour appuyer très insatisfaits ouais
alors là les agents de sécurité ça se
passe
l' aéroport horaire à chicago mais
refuse de quitter l'avion mais
s'accroche
[Musique]
je ne
il va être blessé
interview d'un ehpad compenser
financièrement par la compta y ait
quelques mois plus tard mais on ne sait
pas où il a reçu en compensation donc ça
la question
c'est pas la question voilà il fait très
bien bon alors qu'elle avait visé
l'équipe du temps aujourd'hui pour
quelle raison ce médecin at-il été
expulsé l'essentiel j'avais des choix d
aucune de ces réponses d'accord à il
aurait refusé de s'asseoir dans le siège
qui lui étaient assignées produit l'eau
n'ont cessé pour 30 bull en boule à
perdre à clé mais il était monté par
erreur dans le mauvais vol ou c il
insistait pour utiliser les toilettes
alors qu'il n'y était pas encore
autorisé le viol le vol n'avait pas
encore quitté la piste alors quelle est
la bonne réponse quelles raisons d
aucune de ces réponses at il refusé de
s'asseoir dans le siège ce qui lui était
assignée près du hublot on l'a mis comme
il a préféré prendre le simple facile
quand mes toilettes mais il était monté
par ailleurs dans le mode de vol ou
c'est encore une histoire de toilette
il insistait pour utiliser les toilettes
alors qu'il n'y était pas encore
autorisée moi j'étais raide d aucune de
ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses d'accord moi je
moi je pense je vais prendre une chance
avec a refusé de s'asseoir en sièges qui
étaient assignés près du hublot d'accord
les toilettes
moi je dis étoiles aucune de ces
réponses à ces travaux qui a dit
qu'aucune dose réponse
félicitations vous conservez votre en
boules parce que il y avait comme la
plus sûre bouquet la survenance ou
venise à réduire
vous auriez dû mais ce sera meilleure
chance la prochaine fois
alors vous êtes maintenant 70 boules
70's ball et vous avez encore vous
symbole
ok on est prêts pour notre deuxième
éviter ce cas on va l'appeler on va
prendre le temps de la clé il s'agit de
monsieur meyrannes et brahimi qui est
professeur directeur du groupe d'étude
en management des entreprises de
l'aéronautique de l'école des sciences
de la gestion l'université du québec à
montréal entend dire les choses pour
qu'on puisse établir
j'avais remarqué dans les titres louis
100 litres universitaire c'est une carte
d'affaires est un peu la grande affiche
comme celle ci à la saison et c'est
quelqu'un qu'on voit assez souvent à la
télé on lui demande son avis sur toutes
sortes d'êtres les questions c'est un
sport exactement d'accord alors je vais
demander à la tour de contrôle la tour
de contrôle est ce que c'est parfait
ouais alors monsieur ibrahim sy voulez
vous s'il vous plaît activer votre vidéo
vous presser sur le bouton petit bouton
carré je pense qu'ils aient indique que
c'est une envie une image mais que c'est
bien
lorsqu'on n'a pas pris du retard en
effet un matin ouais c'est fantastique
écoutez on a eu on a eu un premier
invité de vols en retard qui nous a
expliqué que les indemnités prévues ce
n'était pas suffisant mais j'ai lu un
article à votre sujet qui disait écouter
les compagnies aériennes ont des
responsabilités c'est certain mais on
n'est pas non seulement parfait et
exiger d'être le monde parfait sinon
seulement probablement impossible mais
même peut-être un peu dangereux pour
l'on peut vous nous expliquez vous le
fond de votre pensée
en fait c'est pas que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la responsabilité des
compagnies ne le fait que justement ils
ne peuvent pas juste au nom de nos
profits ou efficacité opérationnelle de
faire n'importe quoi
je disais simplement les choses un
complexe que ça prenons un exemple
simple les pieds le prix des billets
d'avion dans les 10 15 dernières années
n'a cessé de diminuer d'accord on
pourrait dire dans le même contexte
globalement le coût de l'opération
des compagnies aériennes ont augmenté
c'est à dire le prix du kérosène que ce
soit les salaires que ça soit s'ils
voulaient même la valeur nominale donc
des avions alors donc on avis bien sûr
arriver le phénomène des locaux ce qui a
permis donc avoir moins de services à
bord et donc réduire entre le coup mais
les compagnies aériennes doivent
composer avec ces éléments là c'est à
dire ddd des prix moins élevé pour le
billet également
okla si vous voulez le prix de queiroz
et sur lequel ils ont aucun contrôle
donc il faut un petit peu comprendre le
modèle d'affaires des compagnies
aériennes c'est de faire des profits
bien sûr le c est avec un certain nombre
d'éléments sur lequel ils ont un
contrôle et sur d'autres éléments une
opa de contrôle alors ce qui fait que là
ils peuvent aller chercher le maximum
par exemple il ya dix ans ou 15 ans on
aurait été surpris d'entendre qu'une
compagnie aérienne fait payer ses
passagers pour finalement je dirais les
bagages vous savez y ait des compagnies
comme ryanair qui a même demandé la
possibilité chez boeing pour voir si on
peut faire le payer pour aller aux
toilettes
ryanair a même demandé pour voir si on
peut s'arranger pour avoir la suite de
la la position debout dans certains
avions pour le court trajet entre
londres et paris par exemple voyez donc
on va aller chercher l'argent là où
alors il est évident que c'est cesser
les indemnités c'est le dernier de leurs
soucis judiciaires
je vois ici un avion il y aurait des
hamacs et 5,6 à mac en hauteur je suis
dit on prend en maths du monde dans ses
avions la salle entre les places debout
ou si on pourrait être encore plus mais
c'est ça qu'est ce que la législation
fédérale pas ce qui a été annoncé
là où est ce que ça pourrait être
améliorée parce que en europe
ils font mieux on allait chez free fait
mieux au niveau du montant oui vous
savez raisons d'abord il faut quand même
être des choses encore nous sommes sur
un vaste territoire qui le canada avec
une densité de population qui est fait
alors donc ce qui fait que les vols à
l'intérieur du pays c'est pas comme en
europe arrêté superficie inférieure là
se passe de du canada mais avec 450
millions d'habitants d'autres il ya une
fréquentation beaucoup plus grande des
trajets des vols des avions et tout ça
en journée on a on n'a pas ça donc ce
qui fait que quelque part les compagnies
aériennes nationales quoi pour les
trajets nationaux
ils sont ils sont j'allais dire
avère très radin les choses comme elles
sont
alors la chose peut-être qui pose
problème pour moi
au-delà des questions de tarifs et tout
ça et c'est ça peut-être la grande
différence avec l'europe c'est que
contient différents que ce soit à cause
d'une annulation que ce soit à cause
d'un retard le fardeau de la preuve
c'est sur les épaules si vous voulez de
la compagnie aérienne
c'est à la compagnie aérienne de montrer
que basso l'annulation était pour des
réseaux par exemple de métérologie pour
des raisons de mécanique imprévues alors
que canada et ça c'est très
problématique le fardeau de la preuve
c'est sont les épaules de passagers
sachant que seulement 2% des passagers
canadiens connaissent leurs droits en ce
qui concerne le transport aérien et ce
parmi ses 2 % qui connaissent leurs
droits
il y en a très peu finalement même s'ils
connaissent leurs droits qui vont de
l'avant pourquoi parce que son passager
de prouver que la compagnie le prix
mécanique n'était pas prévisible
alors comment vous voulez que monsieur
madame tout le monde qui prend l'avion
pour aller à toronto pour participer à
une conférence
sache que le bris mécanique au niveau du
moteur ou au niveau du système avionique
aux stéroïdes mollet n'étaient pas
visibles ça vous savez donc c'est simple
je pense philosophiquement parlant au
coeur même de ce cette loi dont le fait
de mettre ça sur les sur le taux de
passage et c'est d'une certaine manière
on lui enlever son droit si vous voulez
ça je pense que l'élément le plus
problématique dans cette loi les
questions autour de la table mais moi
j'ai une question concernant l'éthique
d'une entreprise face à son client parce
qu'on sent de plus en plus en tant que
passager comme un pas en otage parce que
dans le fond ils peuvent décider tout
d'un coup bon il ya plus de nourriture
de servir on ne peut le droit de mettet
des bagages
gratuitement dans la soute puis nous
sommes normalement la philosophie d'une
entreprise c'est le client est roi là
c'est la satisfaction du client
c'est ce qui prime mais on sent pas ça
du tout vous trouvez pas que c'est un
peu un problème ils sont pas comme
oblige il est certain c'est un problème
et vous avez tout à fait raison
par contre envie de vous dire écoutez
prenez un pro trajet de montréal paris
avec n'importe quelle compagnie
conventionnel et puis la classe affaires
vous allez voir à quel point ses droits
ou rennes
ouais ouais c'est ça alors le problème
c'est que vous savez prenons pas dans le
cas d'air canada air canada des places
60 mille personnes par jour alors
qu'elle l'a fait beaucoup d'argent sur
ces trajets internationaux d'accord et
sur le plan national continuera
aircanada à la rigueur on peut dire
demain pour un trajet de toronto
vancouver pour moi c'est pas si rentable
que st est donc à ce moment là je dois
aller chercher pour rentabiliser mon vol
il va falloir que je sur réserve un
surbooking au monde disent nos amis
français donc donc aller au delà de ça
pour que aucun siège reste vite parce
que dans un avion un siège vide un avion
qui décolle avec un signe que ça coûte
cher alors je vais vers st donc le
problème c'est que enfin c'est pas un
problème mais je dire il ya une réalité
un fait nouveau c'est que le transport
aérien s'est beaucoup démocratisé et
donc le fait de prendre de plus en plus
d'avions
un dock ça entre dans les moeurs mais
les compagnies pour aller chercher le
maximum de ses passagers qui ne sont
plus de passagers 10 à 20 ans 30 ans ou
prendre l'avion c'était c'était destiné
à une couche de la société relativement
aisée plus donc les compagnies aériennes
pour rester toujours dans une marge
bénéficiaire
ils sont bien sûr poussé à générer un
certain comportement qui comment je
pourrais dire qui fait en sorte que vous
ne pouvez pas être dans l'est dans les
catégories de prix que la majorité des
gens prennent vous ne pouvez pas être
considérée comme elle
on voit donc nouer avec blue et il avait
pas de réponse à ce qu'on doit
comprendre que c'est aussi la
philosophie du ministre garneau que de
laisser un peu de deux marques de jeux
aux compagnies aériennes canadiennes
alors il ya toute chose qu'il faut dire
par rapport à ça je pense d'abord qu'il
ya un élément qui est le dernier élément
encore une fois philosophique si vous
voulez c'est dans l'air du temps à
accepter ce modèle là tu as aussi
longtemps que l'on ne remet pas en cause
cette approche je les dires du
capitalisme leur âge elles en sont là
sur le groupe qu'il faut c'est à dire
que les compagnies à partir du mans qui
ne sont plus des compagnies nationales
dans le sens public appartenant à l'état
dont la laune mandat ou la finalité de
faire des profits c'est leur première
première priorité
n'oubliez pas qu'à l'époque où le sou
mille tonnes par exemple été le pdg de
air canada il a fait la maison mère mais
après il a créé air canada qui est
devenue une filiale de maison mère à ses
yeux et il a vendu toutes les unités qui
était le service technique qui a donné
si vous voulez l'histoire de avait rossé
autres il a vendu donc aéro plan
maintenant ils leur achètent m'enfin
tout ça c'était pour quoi pour aller
chercher de l'argent il met ça dans la
poche des actionnaires dr paixhans la
cliente n'est plus roi n'est pas leur
seul actionnaire
les rois alors c'est autre chose c'est
que nous sommes dans un pays où la force
de lobbying des compagnies aériennes
notamment les deux ou trois grandes
compagnies au je dirais même la
compagnie principal qui air canada
la force de lobbying auprès des
dirigeants politiques et très grande
favorite et les gens fait au niveau
fédéral puisque l'aviation c'est la
juridiction fédérale
donc cette cette force de mobbing est
très très forte et donc à ce titre là
donc là là là
souvent les désirs des compagnies
aériennes et est générée très bien
écouter on y voit deux dirigeants je
donne un exemple simple pratiquement
partout à travers le monde les pilotes
ont renouvelé leur licence de pilotage
sur leur catégorie d'avions doivent
suivre un certain
d'heures de formation dans le simulateur
donc tous les six mois ses c'est à peu
près donc tous les six mois
l'estrie pratiquement la seule compagnie
à ma connaissance qu'elle dérogation à
cette loi là à 7 à ce principe là c'est
air canada et eux ils font ça tous les
huit mois
alors c'est très rentable pour la
compagnie au lieu d'avoir tous les six
mois la pilotant le simulateur vous leur
tirez dans l'avion vous dormez dormez
dans le simulateur vous faites deux mois
de plus pourquoi pourtant c'est bien ce
que les pilotes ici sont plus
expérimentés
parce qu'on est donc à l'abordage non
nos potes
nos pilotes sont des bons pilotes on a
des bons pilotes main un bon pilote
reste de bons kilos tant qu'ils sont
très tranquille qu'il vous savez dans
99% des cas pilote dale grant n'a pas
grand chose à faire c'est au moment où
il ya quelque chose d'imprévu qui arrive
que le pilote doit faire preuve de sa
compétence mais pour être alerte pour
pouvoir réagir c'est une panne de moteur
c'est un système hydraulique ils
achètent tout ça c'est ce genre
d'exercice qu'on fait dans le simulateur
conseils expérimentés ou pas si vous ne
faites pas quelque chose monde incertain
vous êtes moins à l'aise pour le pour le
présenter dans une situation de stress
alors donc ce qui fait que même si nos
pilotes sont expérimentés et nos pilotes
sont pas plus expérimenté que lufthansa
ou compte asthme ça mais quand on
regarde rejet de leur programme de
formation cesser aussi sérieux aussi
sévère où on n'a pas réduit parce que
les pilotes sont plus le performant
alors tout ça c'est pour vous dire que
nous avons un pouvoir de leur big auprès
de gouvernements et se trouve que nos
ministres de transport vraiment un
langage politique et les progrès sont
lents à réagir par rapport à sa
séparation par rapport aux le droit des
passagers mais parlons par exemple les
fatigue des pilotes nous sommes sont 182
pin 980 unis un pays si vous voulez tout
ce qui concerne la fatigue des pilotes
tout ça c'est si vous voulez ça fait
partie de cette espèce de paquets si je
peux me permettre d'en que ce terme là
il va falloir se quitter on est en
approche finale car isabelle vous êtes
pilote merci beaucoup monsieur ibrahim
et pour votre participation aujourd'hui
alors c'était mes rallyes permis de
l'école des sciences de la gestion
université du québec à montréal
marisa parlait parce qu'elle connaît ça
le pilotage avait piloté près tout à
fait d'accord avec son indice parce que
c'est sûr que les pilotes canadiens font
de plus grandes distances
ils sont habitués et c'est pour ça que
j'étais peut-être pas tout à fait
d'accord avec la dernière partie alors
on va aller vers 50 boules à perdre
alors on rappelle les cornes semboules
72 78 cents policiers aussi à l'avenant
alors voici six mille non pas six mille
six millions cinq cent mille vols au
canada deux compagnies canadiennes ou
étrangères ont été analysés par
l'association vols en retard dont on a
reçu le patron un peu plus tôt sur skype
c'était en 2016 on voulait déterminer
combien 6 millions cinq cent mille vols
ou canada 2016 d'accord quel est le
pourcentage de ces vols qui ont quitté
le sol vers leur destination en retard s
à 15%
b 25 % c'est 35 % d aucune de ces
réponses d aucune de ces réponses ne
diriez quoi
cinquante cinq ans la moitié se fera non
pas si on sera à 15 % 15 % à marie ben
moi je dirais des mechs rai 1
je sais pas me direz peut-être autour
d'eux c'est peut-être pour ça autour de
7 8% alors marie-claude vous conservez
vos symboles cette série 15% des vols au
pays on était bâtard 2016
c'était 12 % en 2014 aucun ne s'améliore
pas voilà moi je remarque que le bras le
véritable problème c'est que trop de
passagers que c'est pas le plus à la
compagnie phonak s'il avait écouté je
vais demander à la tour dont la tour de
contrôle à nous dire si on peut prendre
encore quatre minutes d'émission où
c'est le temps de
acquérir parce que là on nous on
pourrait passer la dernière vidéo très
bien on la passe pas tout de suite
c'est l'image la semaine c'est la
réponse à la question quelle est l'image
cette semaine
si jamais on peut mettre ta petit thème
musical sous ce moment de tension des
missions attention ça me rappelle bobino
et des lunettes
ouais alors écoutez on y voit avec
quelle est selon vous la l'image cette
semaine images où je réponds pas moins
par mois non à vos annonces à vos
nombreuses questions
mais c'est trudeau non ça n'a rien à
voir le monsieur trudeau car c'est
quelqu'un qui est bilingue
garneau ouais ok je vous pose cette
question je me suis tout de quelques
questions quelle image que je retrouve
cette semaine
ça fait longtemps on va la regarder
ensemble je pense c'est ça m'arrive pas
souvent ça mais quand même deviner
essayer de deviner ça pourrait être quoi
ah ouais bah oui animateur de l'émission
c'est moi j'ai prédit la science est
génial ce qui est un très bon français
inutiles et à canal pour monter son
vainqueur ce trophée très sympathique du
castor et les quatre petites répliques
vous voyez devant moi l'année dernière
ce trophée fut remporté par l'équipe
gilles n'importe qui ça s'est tourné en
1989 170 70 quelque chose 66 ans
avant de partir les états unis on a
appris cette semaine qu'il était
souffrait d'un cancer stade iv du
pancréas donc ça c'est un diagnostic
très très très grave
épouvantable c'est une nounou siens des
gains des grands canadiens
écoutez moi je le regarde depuis trois
ans je regardais pas avant je n'ai pas
de connaissances générales donc j'écoute
j'applaudis pourquoi j'en apprends des
choses c'est fou oui oui et puis donc je
m'amuse tous les soirs j'ai pré
enregistré et là j'arrête à chaque fois
qu'ils posent une question qui me donne
le temps de répondre mais moi je partais
avec sa femme c'est quoi la capitale du
kenya
je ne sais pas moi d'aller au but alors
s'amuser mais j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour cet homme là parce que quand il est
à la télévision à l'internet de ses
animateurs qui sont allés aux états unis
comme péter jennings qui était grand
lecteur de nouvelles
oui exactement lentement way qui fait
[Musique]
aussi king
non non il kiffe je crois ok on va vous
croire
et puis c'est très bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à cette émission cette
semaine rappelez vous arrêtez de prendre
l'avion
[Rires]
merci beaucoup à ma raison de simard
maryse joissains a fait plaisir raymond
des marteaux à la semaine prochaine tout
le monde